if success is contingent on a good plan
education and execution in a driven
mindset what do you think makes
businesses fall apart when all of these
factors have been met some businesses
are just tough I mean a significant
percentage you know the restaurants that
open up this year are going to fail I
mean there are a lot of tough businesses
I've always said if you want to be
regarded as a great business person find
a great business it's very important to
get on the right train if you want to
get on a train it's going to go 90 miles
an hour right and not one that's going
to go 30 miles an hour and you're going
to try to figure out how to push it
along a little faster right so it really
does make a huge difference there are
some businesses that are inherently
there's far more opportunity than others
so you want to give a lot of thought to
what train you're getting on when I was
I don't know 21 or 22 in a service
station it's a lousy business you know
we had a guy right next to us he would
cut our prices it's important to get on
the right train and and you really want
to go to work for somebody you admire
some businesses are just easier to build
on the scale than others some businesses
have a high growth market and some of
them are slow growth it doesn't mean
that you can't win but the opportunity
is going to be much different the upside
is going to be much different depending
on the market that you're going into
I'd love to say that a successful
entrepreneur is one who combines what
you love doing with the word as an
opportunity if you love doing it but
there's no opportunity or it's really
small then you've got a hobby it can be
really fulfilling hobby but it's when
you love doing it and there's a big
opportunity that's when you start to win
now if there's a big opportunity you
don't love doing it you're not going to
win either you can build an okay
business if there's a big opportunity
but you don't like doing it but only for
so long because then you're going to
quit you're going to hate your life
because you're waking up every day and
doing work that you don't like doing and
you're gonna quit this is where a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle they do one of
those two things they try to start a
business just around their hobby what
they're passionate about but there's no
Market opportunity they don't know how
to tie it into real demand so they never
build a business just a hobby on the
weekends in the events or
they're just chasing the hot opportunity
and they don't care about the business
and so either way you're going to lose
in both those scenarios you win by doing
the work that you love
that has a big opportunity upside to you
as well I want to share two quick
examples uh that happened to me in the
past week that I think could be really
relevant and valuable one was a dear
friend of mine asked me what social
media platforms am I focusing on and
we're talking about Instagram because he
he wants to go more hardcore Instagram
want to know what I was doing on
Instagram and I said you know what right
now I'm not doing much on Instagram
you know I'm not spending a lot of my
effort my time my energy on Instagram I
love serving I love helping I love
getting the message out there I want to
do it in a way that has the biggest
potential for impact and reach in the
projects I'm working on so he said well
where are you spending your effort and
energy well YouTube is still number one
YouTube is number one because YouTube is
still the best place to get your message
across
it has been for the past couple years
and it's only getting bigger more people
are going to YouTube for content for
Education it's only getting bigger so
YouTube is still number one but then
after YouTube where am I spending most
of my time
Twitter
and Discord
Discord I think is the best place to be
for community and Twitter
it's surprising how how much Twitter has
picked up Twitter was one of the first
social networks I was on and I I not
left it but kind of ignored it for years
and now it's back it's back baby so I'm
spending a lot of my time on Twitter and
Discord and of course YouTube
and why well because that's where people
are that's where the impact is that's
where you get your message out and so I
don't care about the platform I care
about reaching people so you could spend
all day long working on on Instagram or
you could have spent all day long still
if you were working on MySpace creating
your account does Myspace still exist I
don't even know
it's just not a big opportunity
and so yeah again what do I care about I
care about helping entrepreneurs I care
about getting a message out there so
then it becomes using your head okay
where's the opportunity YouTube Discord
Twitter PS if you want to join my
Discord server it's free I'm there every
day Evan carmichael.biz come check us
out
example was I'm talking to a successful
entrepreneur who wants to move from his
big business that he's built tens of
millions of dollars in Revenue to
starting a business to help other
entrepreneurs get their companies going
and he's having a hard time getting this
thing off the ground and is having a
hard time monetizing it
and he's having a hard time getting
people to pay him for things
and I said well the immediate
opportunity you know if you have a long
Horizon great you'll you'll eventually
win because your brain will play out
you'll get better at them at the game
Etc but
the best thing that you can do right now
if you want to monetize it is coach
people who are
inside of your industry that you have
domain expertise because what he's
coming out doing is just helping people
with personal development coming in
helping them believe in themselves
helping them overcome their living
beliefs you know uh helping them
fixed our mindset get their schedule
right all that stuff but then if they're
off building their own business
he's only adding one little piece now
imagine if you could add the tactical
information in the contacts as well as
the mindset and the motivation so
there's two entrepreneurs three
entrepreneurs that I invested into
recently Drew
Jeremy and Bo and these three guys
some of them had no experience I think
Jeremy had he was a stock boy at a
grocery store and you know he's mid six
figures Revenue 18 months later why well
because yes I'm giving him the belief in
the mindset and the motivation but I can
also give him contacts I can also make
introductions for him I can also give
him information about the industry to
know what he's doing right and what he's
doing wrong and so when I'm looking at
making an investment into an
entrepreneur I want to be able to help
them Beyond just believe because I can
get believed to anybody but who would I
want to give believe to that had the
highest impact for success is going to
be people who I can give contacts to
Jeremy does YouTube Consulting there's
people who contact me all the time for
YouTube Consulting I don't want to do it
I don't want to be in that business so I
can give it to Jeremy perfect but if you
were a you know I don't know you were an
arborist can you see the trees I guess
that it's kind of blurry
um if you're an arborist I could help
you believe in yourself I can give you
some business model ideas but I can't
make contacts or introductions for you
and so you have to be smart about the
opportunities you take on
has to be something that you
deeply deeply deeply care about
and then inside that find the
opportunity
because the market is moving and the
market hopefully is getting bigger and
if you're inside a growing market and
you love what you're doing that's a slam
dunk that's a home run for you so
what's the methodology now to help
figure that out well one you have to
start with what do you naturally just
love doing what do you love doing what
can you wake up and get what do you what
do you get in Lost in where are you
spending your time what are you
daydreaming about don't not about the
result not about the cars and the yachts
and the whatever right not that that
that's a result that what do you get
lost in the process of doing what
industry do you actually care about
where are you spending your time where
are you researching what doesn't feel
like work for you right so that's Step
One is is connecting to something that
you're actually passionate about not
just trying to make money right make
money is important but it's not step
number one
figure out that idea next is okay how do
we turn that into a market opportunity
where is the business actually growing
that we can connect our our talents and
our passions to so if you love send if
you love sharing a message like my first
example great now be strategic about the
platform that you're going to pick
it used to be Instagram now it's YouTube
Twitter and Discord
if you love coaching people and
Consulting and investing in people great
connected to where you actually have
domain expertise and can make
introductions for people and take a
piece of their business as opposed to
just charging for the hour
or just helping people with mindset and
not actually introductions and tactics
right so you love the opportunity it
makes you come alive thinking about it
and
there's actually something for you to
grow
right logically strategically is a way
for you to make money doing it when you
can combine those two things you have a
much much much much much much higher
degree of success
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
I would encourage you if you're
interested in the field to do a few
things I'm still trying to make them as
intelligent as possible I would try to
stick with things businesses I thought I
understood I'd still get out that sheet
of paper and I'd write I'm doing this
because and just test my reasoning and
then I go back and read it a year later
and and see whether what you thought
would be true turned out to be true so I
would always check myself I believe in
grading myself on everything you know
doctors have postmortems and they they
do it because they learn from
postmortems uh and business people don't
like to do postmortem so I'm I'm I can
be on the board of a company and they
never wanted two years later to run a
check on how that decision turned out
because it it can be unpleasant uh but
you learn from postmortems and uh you
don't want to learn it's way better
learn from other people's mistakes than
your own but you got to learn from a few
of your own too and the time to do it is
when you're young the allowance when I
was a little boy was a nickel a week but
I like the idea of having a little more
than a nickel a week to work with and I
went into business very early
I started selling Coca-Cola door-to-door
I sold them door-to-door or sold
Saturday in post Liberty magazine ladies
home Turtle you name it
[Music]
I think I enjoyed the game almost right
from the start
I'm boss
I like about delivering papers
I got arrange the route I wanted nobody
was bothering me at five or six in the
morning
500 papers a day and I made a penny of
paper but in terms of compounding that
Penny shirt into something else people
ask me what they should take in business
school and and uh or even if they don't
go to business school what they need to
know before getting in business and I
tell them you know you have to you have
to understand accounting it's the
language of it it would be it's like
being in a foreign country without
knowing the language if you're in
business and you don't understand
accounting so it it it you want to get
as comfortable with that
as you are with the English language it
it's made me uh a lot of money because I
I listen to what Ray Dean had to say 53
or four years ago and have been able to
understand uh
uh what I was seeing on pieces of paper
what that told me about businesses and
the limitations of what it told me about
businesses I mean Henry Ford as you may
know failed twice before he started the
Ford Motor Company in 1903 I mean the
the test isn't whether you get the
greatest
business idea in the world the first
time out the test is whether you keep
learning as you go along what your
strengths are and what you can do for
your customers what you can bring
especially to the party you need a
genuine
a genuine desired day in day out to
Delight the customer
I've never I've never seen a business
and I've seen a lot of businesses but
I've never seen one that Delights the
customer
that that doesn't succeed I mean what
you want is that customer the next day
when they think do I want to rent a car
or do I want to buy some furniture
and what goes through their mind you
know it's the place where they've had a
great experience I don't know what
I paid for this
type actually probably if somebody gave
it to me but for the purposes of the
speech I will say I I have no idea but
what I or the shirt I'm wearing others
but I do know I will remember
how I was treated
when I bought it I mean you long forget
about the price but you never forget
whether you had a good experience or a
poor experience uh with the purchase
experience and I don't need to be in
Washington to figure out what the
Washington Post uh newspaper is worth
and I don't need to be in New York to
figure out what some other company is
worth it's it's simply it's an
intellectual process and unless the less
static there is in that intellectual
process really the better off you are
what is the intellectual process the
intellectual process is
is defining your level defining your
area of competence and valuing
businesses
and then within that area of competence
finding whatever cells at the at the
cheapest price in relation to value and
there are all kinds of things I'm not
competent to Value well there are a few
that I am confident to Value have you
ever bought a technology company no I
really haven't in 30 years of investing
not one I haven't understood any of them
so you haven't ever owned for example
IBM part of this company I made a
sensational company but I haven't known
IBM and so here is this technological
Revolution going on and you're not going
to be a participant going right past me
is that all right with you it's okay
with me I don't have I don't have to
make money in every game I mean I don't
know what cocoa beans are going to do I
don't you know there are all kinds of
things I don't know about and that may
be too bad but uh you know why should I
know all about them I haven't worked
that hard on them in Securities business
you literally every day have thousands
of the major American corporations
offered you at a price and a price that
changes daily
and you don't have to make any decisions
you have to make nothing is forced upon
you so you there are no called strikes
in the business the pitcher just stands
there and throws balls at you and uh if
you're playing real baseball and it's
between the knees and the shoulders you
either swing or you got a strike hold on
if you get too many calls I know you're
out in the Securities business you sit
there and they throw a U.S steel at 25
and they throw General Motors at 68 and
you don't have to swing at any of them
they may be wonderful pitches to swing
at but if you don't know enough you
don't have to swing and you can sit
there and watch thousands of pitches and
finally you get one right there where
you want it something that you
understand and then you swing I've got
this rule the rule you know the first
rule is don't lose in the second rule is
never forget the first rule so it really
isn't so much having a lot of brilliant
decisions it's just not really having
some terrible ones and and and frankly I
did learn from Ben Graham how to avoid
ever having any disasters and
Investments it wasn't that you were
going to come up with the very smartest
thing but if you never have any any
significant losses you know some singles
and doubles will produce a lot of runs
before you get through leadership at
Berkshire
really consists of taking a bunch of
people
who win a baseball uh analogy would be
400 hitters and just handing him the bat
and just telling them to get up the
plate and take a big swing uh there's
very little to it beyond that one thing
I do is I send them a letter the only
thing I tell them
and this letter which went out January
20th 2003 it says it's been two and a
half years since my last memo now how
many big companies have you have the
managers out there been two and a half
years since they've heard from the home
office it's been two and a half years
since my last memo
here are a couple things to keep in mind
and number one and this is number one
every time that this doesn't change it
won't change two years from now or four
years from now or six years number one
we can afford to lose money even a lot
of money
we cannot afford to lose reputation even
a shredder reputation
let's be sure that everything we do in
business can be be reported on the front
page of a national newspaper in an
article written by an unfriendly but
intelligent reporter
in many areas including Acquisitions
berkshire's results have benefited from
its reputation and we don't want to do
anything that in any way can tarnish it
last year Berkshire was ranked by
Fortune as the fourth most admired
company in the world this year we were
third in the United States they just
published it
it took us 37 years to get there but we
could lose it in 37 minutes
and that's the message I mean we you
know we we can lose money it does you
know nicer to make money but we've got
we'll figure out ways to make money
but we can't lose we can't lose a
shredder reputation
because you don't get it back if you
look around you at the people you admire
you know they have certain qualities I
mean you've got you've got friends why
do you like them you know generally you
know that they they generally they have
an upbeat attitude on life generally
they are generous people they're
humorous people they're people that do
more than their share they're people
that are thinking about something nice
they can do for you and all of those
qualities attract you and none of those
are are innate at Birth I mean you you
can acquire those and then there's other
people that turn you off you know and
and uh they have habits they take credit
for things they didn't do they don't
show up on time whatever it may be
they're a little dishonest about things
and
if you're looking at your life at a
young age like you are and you can
choose what kind of a person you can be
why not be the person you admire rather
than the person you can't stand it's so
simple so just write down the qualities
you liked take your take your five best
friends why do you like them and just
write down those qualities and you will
find there's no quality there that you
can you can't have yourself and
similarly with the five people you can't
stand to be around but those put those
things down to turn you off about those
people and if they turn you off about
them why should you possess them it's so
simple uh you know it's not it's not
it's not like some something complicated
that you think you should be learning
instituted as investing in the stock
market I know but
it's it's enormously important to have
people work with you in life right
they're going to work with you in life
if they like you you know and they may
occasionally I mean if you're in the
army or something you know you may work
for somebody that you don't like but by
and large
you're going to get the best out of
people if they feel good about you and
it's just so easy but you've got to
develop the habits early because you
can't say I'm going to suddenly become a
terribly attractive person when I'm 60.
it just doesn't work that way so pick up
the right habits now and
I will guarantee you if you actually
just write down those qualities and
think about it you will find you can
have every one of the attractive
qualities get rid of the ones that are
are negative and your life will be
different I like to read more than most
kids I really like to read a lot
my aunt Edie gave me a copy of the World
Almanac and that was Heaven to me and I
can still tell you that almost
population was 214 0006 in 1930. some
numbers just got to stick with you
and very early probably when I was seven
or so I took this book out of the Benson
Library called a thousand ways to make a
thousand dollars
one of the ways in this book was having
Penny weighing machines
Ted I sat and calculated how much it
would cost to buy the first weighing
machine and then how long that would
take for the profit for that one to buy
another one I would sit there and create
these compound interest tables to figure
out how long it take me to have a
weighing machine for every person in the
world the first books I read on
investment were actually in my dad's
office
[Music]
pretty soon I read all the books in the
office and read some of them more than
once a few years ago I went to Amazon
sure enough they had this manual there
so
while reliving my youth other guys were
going to Amazon probably and and a fine
old Playboys or something but I bought
old movies manuals instead and when I
got out of school I started selling
stocks I was 20 years old at the time
and looked about 16 and acted about 12.
so I was not the most impressive sales
person anybody ever met but what I would
do was I I went through Page by Page
looking for possibly undervalued stocks
yeah I well I mean I've made a lot of
mistakes biggest mistake oh well not the
biggest necessarily the biggest but but
buying Berkshire Hathaway itself was a
mistake because Berkshire was a lousy
textile business and I bought it very
cheap
I'd been taught by Ben Graham to buy
things on a quantitative basis look
around for things that are cheap
and
that I was taught that say in 1949 or so
they made a big impression on me so I
went around looking for what
I call you cigar much of stocks and the
cigar butt approach to buying stocks is
that you walk down the street and you're
looking around for cigar butts and you
find this honestly this terrible looking
soggy ugly looking cigar one puff left
in it but you pick it up and you get
your one puff it's disgusting you throw
it away but it's free I mean it's cheap
and then you look around for another
soggy you know one puff cigarette well
that's what I did for years
it's a mistake uh although you can make
money doing it but you can't make it
with big money it's so much easier just
to buy wonderful businesses so now I
would rather buy a wonderful business at
a fair price than a fair business at a
wonderful price but in those days I was
buying cheap stocks and Berkshire was
selling below its working capital per
share you got the plants for nothing you
got the machinery for nothing you got
the inventory and receivables at the
discount it was cheap so I bought it and
20 years later I was still running a
lousy business and that money did not
compound you really want to be in a
wonderful business because the time is
the friend of the wonderful business you
keep compounding it keeps doing more
business and you keep making more money
time is the enemy of the lousy business
I could have sold Berkshire perhaps
liquidated it and made a quick little
profit you know one Puff
but staying with those kind of
businesses is is a big mistake so you
might say I learned something out of
that mistake and I would have been way
better off taking
what I did with Berkshires I kept buying
better businesses I started the
insurance business to See's Candy the
Buffalo all kinds of things I would have
been way better doing that with a with a
brand new little entity that I'd set up
rather than using Berkshire the platform
now I've had a lot of fun out of it I
mean everything in life seems to turn
out for the better so I I don't have any
complaints about that but it was a dumb
thing to do
I went in the U.S air
I bought a preferred stock in 1989.
as soon as my check cleared the company
went into the red and never got out I
mean it was a really dumb I mean it
um I've got an 800 number I call now
whenever I think about buying an airline
stock I call them up any hour that
fortunately I can call them at three in
the morning and I just dial and I say my
name's Warren I'm an aeroholic you know
and I'm thinking about buying this thing
and they talked me down I mean
takes hours sometimes but it's worth it
believe me if you ever think about that
Airline buying an airline stock call me
and I'll give you the 800 number because
Lucky in terms of how we eventually came
out on it but it was a dumb dumb
decision if you tell me who your heroes
are I can tell you how you're going to
turn out to quite an extent by this
point in life and I I I have been
extraordinarily lucky and that none of
my heroes ever let me down I mean the
ones I came up with
throughout their lives I've never felt
that I've been let down in any way with
it number one was my dad and and uh
had a huge impression on me
my wife who was here is one of my heroes
I mean she is you know in terms of of
she's taught me a tremendous amount and
then and never seen anybody any better
with human beings than she is and you
can Yogi Bear again said you can you can
observe a lot just by watching and uh
I uh you know I I watched my dad and
I've watched her and uh I had a a
professor Ben Graham back at Columbia
and had a huge impact on me so I have
been lucky and that I've had terrific
Heroes and they they haven't let me down
and and uh
that
that takes you a long long way I've gone
through one or two periods where we're
kind of tough in life but not any I mean
every everybody's had had that but but
having the right Heroes will take you
right through it if you buy a business
if you buy a farm you know you go up and
look
you know every couple weeks to see how
far the corn is up and you know do you
worry too much about whether somebody
says this is going to be a year of low
prices because exports are being
affected or anything like that you know
you buy a farm and you hold it for I've
got one farm that I bought in the 1980s
and my son runs it but
I've been there once you know I mean it
it it it doesn't grow faster if I go and
stare at it you know I can't cheer for
it you know more effort more effort or
something like that and I know there's
going to be some years when prices are
going to be good and so when the prices
aren't going to be good I know there's
years when yields will be better than
others but about the farm and and uh
if it just doesn't I don't care about
economic predictions on or anything of
the sort I do care that over over the
years it's well tended to in terms of
rotating crops and I hope yields get
better which they generally have in fact
that farm a hundred years ago would have
probably produced
30 bushels maybe 35 bushels of corn per
acre now in a good year you know it'd be
200 I mean
we really made progress in this country
that's one reason commodity prices have
go back a couple hundred years they've
moved so little is because we've just
gotten better and better at whether it's
cotton or whether it's it's corn or
soybeans or all kinds of things and you
and I have benefited from that and so
Apple's kind of like a farm well it's a
it's a long-term investment and and if
you owned if you're on the the best auto
dealership in town the best brand and
had something good running it wouldn't
drop by every day and say you know how
many people have come in today or you
know I think inter trades are going up a
little maybe I'll slow down our sales or
anything no you'll buy it knowing
there's 365 days a year and you're going
to own it for 20 years so that's 7 300
days and you know they're going to
things are going to be different from
day to day and year to year you
shouldn't buy it up the day-to-day stuff
is important well speaking of resources
let's talk a little bit about your
decision to put your money with Bill and
Melinda Gates uh you are somebody
obviously who's
you know arguably not even arguably
definitively by numbers the best in the
world in terms of figuring out how to
allocate capital I mean dollars don't
lie and then put it to work and yet with
philanthropy you out you basically
outsourced it how did that well that's
true but you know when my wife had a
baby I didn't deliver it either I mean I
you know I
I didn't fill my kid's teeth I mean you
know I I Adam Smith in 1776 explained
specialization of Labor and he did a
pretty good job of that and I feel I'm
very good at at piling up money and and
my wife was very good at unpiling it I
mean it's a very simple formula and she
was going to handle the philanthropy big
time and she did during her lifetime at
a at a moderate level but basically I
was going to turn it all over to her to
handle and I would pile up during my
lifetime and and she died before you
know earlier and and therefore I had to
make a decision as to what was the best
way to use a very large sum of money uh
and and get my goals achieved through
other people and uh there are other
people that are better than I am and all
kinds of things I mean hey Rogers here I
mean you know we're not going to get
into a home run derby
so so I believe in I believe in uh I I
really do believe in getting people that
are younger more energetic but also
experienced and in the case of Bella
Melinda have their own money up as well
and they've got similar they've got
identical objectives really with me and
if I can get them to do the work and I
can keep having fun doing what I do I'll
do it and it's getting the game sure I
bought the first shares of Berkshire in
1962 and it was a northern textile
business destined to become extinct
eventually and uh it was a statistically
cheap stock and a terrible business
Berkshire Hathaway was closing Mills and
as they closed Mills it would free up
some capital and then they would
repurchase shares so I bought some stock
with the idea that there would be
another tender offer at some point and
we would sell the stock at the modest
profit and at one point the management
asked me at what price we would tender
our stock and I said 11.50
and the tender offer came out a few
months later
and uh it was a 11 and 3 8 was an eighth
of a point cheaper
and that made me very mad so I just
started buying more stock
I just felt that I had been double
crossed by the management and in May of
1965 but bought enough so we controlled
the company one of the reasons weren't
successful is he's brutal and appraising
his own past he wants to identify Miss
thinkings and avoid them in the future
but it was an accident that he chose
Berkshire Hathaway if the chairman
hadn't tried to cheat him out of an
eighth there wouldn't have been any
Buffett Dash Berkshire Hathaway history
if you're emotional about investment
you're not going to do well
you may have all these feelings about
the stock the stock has no feelings
about you
looking back it's interesting that
tender offer I didn't realize it but it
happened about five days after my dad
had died and I whether that hadn't
affected me or not I don't know well I
was lucky that I got started early I
mean it always helps me to get started
early and and my dad happened to be an
investment business so I would go down
his office on Saturdays and so at age
probably seven or something I started
reading these books that were around the
place and so I had a 15-year jump on
many people in a sense and that that
helped a lot and and I was always
fascinated by them I knew what I wanted
to do early and I think that's a that's
a huge Advantage too and then you don't
need you don't need a lot of brains in
this business I mean I've always said if
you got an IQ of 160 giveaway 30 points
to somebody else because you don't need
it Investments what you do need is
emotional stability you have to you have
to be able to think independently and
you have to be you have to be
when you come to a conclusion you have
to really not care what other people say
and and just follow the facts and follow
your reasoning and and that's that's
tough for a lot of people that that part
I think I was just lucky with I was born
that way
in terms of emotions it's a truism that
investing emotions are your enemy
absolutely that when the Market's good
if you feel good don't if you feel bad
you should probably do it right but uh
how uh how how did you uh what what was
that extra thing where uh so many will
acknowledge that and yet we saw in the
current crisis they they Panic while you
went into seemingly uh potential
disasters like GE and Goldman Sachs yeah
I can't really tell you the end I mean I
didn't learn in school or anything I
just it never bothered me if people
disagreed with what I thought as long as
I felt I knew the facts I mean there's a
whole bunch of things I don't know a
thing about I just stay away from those
so I still within what I call my circle
of competence you know that Tom Watson
said it best he said you know he said he
said I'm no genius but I'm smart in
spots and I stay around those spots well
I try and stay around those spots and I
I just don't have a a problem if if uh
if somebody says you know you're wrong
on something I just I go back and look
at the facts and and
I think that I think that really is much
more important frankly than than having
a few points of IQ or or having an extra
course or two in in school or anything
of the sort you need emotional stability
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself I mean that for example
communication skills I tell those
students that come that they're going to
graduate schools and business and
they're learning all these complicated
formulas all that if they just learn to
communicate better and both in writing
and in person they increase their value
at least 50 percent and now I mean
if you can't communicate somebody says
you know it's like winking at a girl in
the dark nothing happens you know
basically and and you have to be able to
get
get forth your ideas and uh and that's
that's relatively easy I did it myself
with the Dale Carnegie of course some
people wish I'd taken a shorter course
now my answer is my talking later on but
it it's just hugely important and you if
you invest in yourself nobody can take
it away from you well I look at a lot of
figures just in connection with our
businesses I I
I like to get numbers so so I I'm
getting reports in
weekly in some businesses uh uh that but
that doesn't tell me what the economy is
going to do six months from now or three
months from now it tells me what's going
on now with our businesses uh uh and it
really doesn't make any difference in
what I do today in terms of buying
stocks or buying businesses what those
numbers tell me they're interesting but
they're not they're not guidance to me
if if we buy a business we're going to
hold it forever so we're gonna have good
years bad years in between years maybe
disasters here or something here and and
uh we care a lot about the price we do
not care about the next 12 months
economic predictions just don't enter
into our decisions Charlie mugger my
partner I in
you know 54 years now
we've never made a decision based on an
economic prediction we make business
predictions about what individual
businesses will do over time and we
compare that to what we have to pay for
but we have never said yes to something
because we thought the economy was going
to do well in the next year or two years
and we never said no to anything
because we're right in the middle of a
panic even if the price was right you
know how do you turn failure into a plus
uh and it's true when I was at the
University of Nebraska one day I was
reading the daily Nebraskan
and it said in Room 300 or something at
three o'clock there will be this panel
of three uh uh professors here at the
University and they're going to award
the Nathan gold scholarship I don't know
whether you're still you still have it
around and at the time
uh it said it would give you 500 to go
to The Graduate School of your choice I
don't know whether it's changing amount
but but that that was it so I read this
and I went there to this room at three
o'clock that day or whatever it was and
I walked in the room
and there were the professors
and I was the only student that showed
up I mean it really got to him I mean
they were stuck they you know they kept
waiting and looking at their watching
hoping there'd be more candidates but
there no one came in so I won 500 by by
default and
those are usually my biggest triumphs
when nobody else shows up
and so here I was I had five hundred
dollars to go toward any it wasn't it
wasn't the limiters any any graduate
school for a master's degree so I
applied to Harvard my dad wanted me to
and uh
uh I shortly heard from Harvard
and they said go to Chicago and meet
this fellow running that who interviews
applicants from the Midwest
so I got on the train and that's what
you did in those days and I spent about
10 hours on the Burlington going to
Chicago then I transferred to another
little Interurban train to go up to this
Country Day School where this fellow was
the Headmaster and he was the big
interviewer for Harvard
and I got there and after about
10 minutes he he said better think about
something else that uh you know he uh
come back later on I was I was 19 at the
time and uh I looked about 12. you know
and and I and I acted about eight uh it
was not a great combination uh but so he
he said forget it so I spent I took the
little Interurban train back to Chicago
and I took the 10-hour train back to
Oman all the time you know what do I
tell my parents you know it's kind of
embarrassing uh but
it was it was the luckiest thing ever
happened to me I because
if I'd gone to Harvard I would have gone
to a two-year
business school i i instead applied to
Columbia where I could graduate in one
year and get a master's degree
luckily
that by the accident of it and being in
the Nebraska National Guard which did
not get called up for the Korean War
I missed going in the Korean War
I
I got to meet Ben Graham and which had
an enormous effect on me subsequently
and I probably got my wife that way
because she was going to Northwestern
and I was able to put on sort of a full
court press because I got out in one
year and otherwise uh she'd she'd have
met some other guy I mean I I got her
before the competition showed up and uh
so it worked out wonderfully it couldn't
have worked out better and that's been
that's been my life basically I mean it
the things you know you will get some
disappointments you know uh but if I
knew every decision I was going to make
was going to be perfect it would not be
as much money like playing golf and
knowing you're going to hit a hole in
one on every hole you wouldn't play golf
if every time you got on a tee you just
took a swing and the ball ended up in
the hole you know be fun for a few days
and get on TV but it the game would not
be any fun so it's failure you know and
I wouldn't even consider him failures
but their mistakes or whatever you want
to call it they're they're part of the
game and in the end you know you go on
and and we've made plenty of mistakes in
business we'll make plenty more and the
the you know the
Babe Ruth and you know for a long time
they subsequently got eclipsed by a few
fellows but uh he held the record for
strikeouts you know so the hell the
record for home runs and was the highest
paid baseball player until
the modern era came along and so it's
it's part of the game if you take big
swings you know you yeah it may you may
you're going to miss sometimes I would
like to tell you of two women
uh that each sold the business
to Berkshire Hathaway uh to me actually
for many many many millions of dollars
most of them started with twenty five
hundred dollars by a coincidence was the
exact same amount it was everything they
had in the world and one of them
was a woman
who landed in Seattle in 1917
couldn't speak a word of English
had a tag around her neck
the tags said uh
Fort Dodge Iowa
the Red Cross daughter and a Fort Dodge
where she was reunited with her husband
who had come to the country a couple of
years earlier
and she lived in Fort Dodge for two
years and as she put it
she felt like a dummy
she couldn't pick up the language she
couldn't learn a word
and so she decided she and her husband
decided
to move to Omaha
so they came to Omaha
in 1919
and there she found a
small colony of Russian Jews so she
started feeling more at home and then as
her oldest daughter went to school
she would come home this daughter
Francis
and she would teach her mother the words
she'd learned in school that day
and this woman Rose blumpkin
spent 20 years
saving money
bringing first her siblings over
her mother and father
fifty dollars at a time she sold used
clothing to do it
she had four children during this period
and by 1937 after 20 years
she'd save twenty five hundred dollars
she went to Chicago
and she bought when she could have
furniture her dream and always been the
open a furniture store
and this woman without who had never
gone to school one day in her life
with twenty five hundred dollars
but with the same spirit that the people
in this room had
about having a dream and working to
accomplish that dream
she built a business
which she sold to me
in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in
which
which did a billion and a half dollars
worth of business last year
the fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman Rose blumpkin
lived well she she worked for me until
she was 103. and then I'm not said then
she retired and she died the next year
which is a lesson to all of berkshire's
managers that
premature retirement you know nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but Mrs B
with their twenty five hundred dollars
one further fact about her
she could not read or write
and she went into a Furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in Furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed
she knew she could outwork anyone else
she knew that she cared about her
customers
she worked at very low gross margins but
she built this incredible business Laura
what do you consider the most important
quality for an investment manager
it's the temperamental quality not an
intellectual quality you don't need tons
of IQ in this business I mean you have
to have enough IQ to get from here to
Downtown Omaha but uh but uh you do not
have to be able to play
three-dimensional chess or be in the top
leagues in terms of bridge playing or
something of sort you need
a stable
personality you need a temperament
that neither derives great pleasure from
being with the crowd or against the
crowd because this is not a business
where you take polls it's a business
where you think
and Ben Graham would say that you're not
right or wrong because a thousand people
agree with you and you're not right or
wrong because a thousand people disagree
with you you're right because your facts
and your reasoning are right how do you
know when to throw in the towel on an
investment or a business I might be
throwing the top on a investment or
business business yeah well you what you
know you're doing too late
I went in the textile business by
accident in 1965
and I threw in the towel about 20 years
later and that was about 20 years too
late
the there's a great tendency to want to
hold on justify old decisions I mean
that's a human human trait and uh
what when you really know you've got a
bad business is when you have a good
manager and you're getting bad results I
mean when you when you're when you're
getting bad results with a bad manager
you still have to examine the question
of whether you know you can get better
results if you got a better manager
usually you can't you know I've said in
the past you know that when a when a
management with a reputation for
excellence
encounters a business with a reputation
for bad economics it's the reputation of
the business that remains intact and and
I've proved that many times uh
there are businesses that are just plain
tough you know and there's the guy
there may be too many competitors but
there's reasons why they don't drop out
there's reasons well we we started out
in textiles and we made over half of the
uh the linings for men's suits in the
country and we we went through World War
II and got Awards and and Sears Roebuck
named us their supplier of the year and
all of that sort of thing and then we'd
say Well we'd like to increase the price
of of these Linings a quarter of us in a
yard and seriously must be out of your
mind there's 10 other guys that will
sell them to us at the old price and
nobody ever went into a Sears store and
said I'd like a a blue surge shirt blue
shirt surge suit with a half away lining
you know it didn't exist we had no
connection to the consumer and there are
lots of lousy businesses you know and
there's lots of wonderful businesses and
or my job over the years has been to try
and figure out which is which and I've
made plenty of mistakes I bought a
company called Dexter shoes in the early
90s I paid 400 plus million dollars for
it and it it made a lot of money before
I bought it but you know as soon as I
bought it they pulled some switch or
something and immediately he started
losing money and uh and it was because
of foreign competition so on or it was
maybe it's because I owned it I don't
know uh and it went to zero and the
worst thing was that I paid for it in
stock so that 400 million in stock I
gave at the time is uh now worth about
five billion so it uh so uh every time
Berkshire stock goes down I feel a
little bit better because of my
opportunity loss on this business but
you know when I looked at Dexter's shoe
they had a good position in retailers
they turned out good shoes they had a
great Workforce all kinds of things but
I just forgot one thing that that they
weren't going to make shoes in the
United States anymore so you make you
make mistakes and it does pay to
recognize quickly when you made them if
you've got a good person running a
business and it isn't making any money
uh you know you're in the wrong business
and and you've got to face up to that
when you get to my age you will not
measure how well you've done by how much
money you've got I can guarantee you
that you'll all do fine on money anyway
I mean uh you know think about it seven
hours a day you know you're in a bed you
got exactly the same mattress I've got
if you don't whistle it to you at the
furniture mark you know I mean so so
that I mean we're on a parody I can't I
can't outdo you you know in terms of my
sleeping enjoyment you can you can match
it by by buying this mattress which will
give you a special price on just mention
my name
we eat at the same places you know we
eat a Dairy Queen particularly if you're
in my position because we own it but but
we eat up dolls in Burger King and and
when I leave here I'll stop by a fast
food place I mean I had a 10 year old
car up until about a year ago you know
and it just doesn't make any difference
to me they all work we live in a place
that's warm in the winter and it's cool
in the summer and we watch the Super
Bowl on big screen TV you do what I do
it you know we dress more or less the
same I mean I pay more for my clothes
but they look cheap when I put them on
so we're really on we're on a parody
yeah so so the money isn't going to be
that big a deal everybody in this
country is going to you know that with
the intelligence this group has the
energy you have you're going to do well
so what's the difference you know what
really counts well I would say that you
will measure health is enormously
important and that's a matter of a fair
amount of luck I mean you know so I
won't I don't I'm not sure changing it
I'm just saying you can't do too much
about that but
you will measure your success in life
by whether by how many and extent
whether it's the people you want
at 70 or whatever the age may be you'll
measured by how many of them really love
you you know in the end I mean you can't
you know you you can't buy love I mean
it doesn't work you buy sex you can buy
testimonial dinners you can buy your
name on buildings you can do all kinds
of things but the you know the only way
you get to be you know love is to be
lovable it's kind of irritating actually
you've got a lot of money it'd be more
fun to just write out a check for a
million dollars that's everybody you
know from now on loves me but it doesn't
work that way and in fact it the only
way is to be is to be lovable and and
you know I've got this friend
who uh who came out of Auschwitz
and had at least one member of the
family die there
and
what is it now it's uh
60 years later
you know she's still when she looks at
people it's a polished Jew when she
looks at people
the question she asks herself in
determining who she really trusts as
friends the one question in her mind is
would they hide me
now when you get to be 70
if you've got a lot of people that would
hide you you've had a successful life
I know people who have a tremendous
amount of money no one would hide their
own kids wouldn't hide them I mean they
they really wouldn't I mean their
business associates wouldn't or anybody
else if it really came down to it
you know that they they don't have
anybody's respect they've got their
attention maybe with money or something
of the sort but they they nobody loves
them and uh my friend Tom Murphy at
Campus of hdb I mean dozens of people
would hide Murph you know all kinds of
people would would hide my wife you know
that uh Ben Graham A lot of people my
dad it would have had a number and then
like I say that I can I can tell you
people that uh you know everybody May
pay homage to them and the kids may put
up with them and hope they don't change
their will or something but the truth is
that nobody would hide them and if
you've got a lot of people that would
hide you
when you get to be 70 uh you will have
had a very successful life everything
you do learn is cumulative I mean that
doesn't mean that Industries stay good
forever or businesses stay good forever
but but learning to think about business
models what I learned at 20 is useful to
me now what I learned at 25 is useful to
me now and so
it's not it's not so it's not a field
that changes
dramatically in terms of the underlying
principles it's like physics I mean
there's underlying principles now
they're doing all kinds of things with
physics they weren't doing 50 years ago
but but if you know the if you've got
the principles if you know what makes a
good business if you know what makes a
good manager you know if he knows what
makes a a good product
uh
and you learn that in one business you
can there is some transference to other
businesses if you go along and you learn
what things you you're not going to
understand I mean
knowing what to leave out is just as
important as knowing to focus on and uh
I don't think I can win every game you
know somebody said how do you beat Bobby
Fischer you play him any game except
chess so I don't play Bobby Fischer
chess
and that's there's a lot of value to
learning that over time and and learning
what you're good at and what you're not
good at you know the most important
thing
uh
aside from the things I've talked about
already is is really who you associate
with you want to associate with people
that are better than you are I mean
basically you'll go in the direction of
the people that you associate with and
and you want to have the right Heroes uh
you want people if you want to emulate
somebody you better pick very carefully
who you want to emulate and
and one obviously you can't pick your
parents they're going to have enormous
influence on you but you don't get a
choice on that but you get choices as
you go down the line and you
who you uh who you admire who you who
who you want to copy and the most
important for most people in terms of
that decision is their spouse it's also
important in terms of a partner in
business with the partner in life is
is the most important one you want to
pick a spouse that's a little that's
better than you are
and then he or she and you hope they
don't figure it out too fast all of you
in this room
have the brains to do extremely well in
life
you've all got the energy to do
extremely well in life and then the
question is how do you apply it if
you've got a 200 horsepower motor you
get 200 horsepower out of it you get
your full potential or do you get 100
horsepower or 50 horsepower
now there's two things that can
hold you back
in getting the full horsepower out of
your your engine whatever it may be all
of you have big enough engines
and one of those is a lack of education
but that probably isn't going to happen
to very many people in this room if you
did have a lack of Education if you
didn't if you didn't have a chance to
get a decent education in life it
wouldn't make any difference what that
potential was because you'd never unlock
it but the second most important thing
and equally as important
is in terms of the habits that you
develop in terms of what you do with
yourself
when we
hire people we look for three qualities
we look for integrity we look for
intelligence and we look for energy
but if they don't have the first one
Integrity the other two will kill you
because if you're hiring somebody
without Integrity you really want them
to be dumb and lazy don't you I mean the
last thing in the world you want for
them is to be smart and energetic so
smart and energetic only goes with
Integrity you can't change your IQ or
how far you control football or how high
you can jump or the color of your hair
very easily but you can elect
to have integrity that matches anybody
else's and if you match that with
intelligence which you have and energy
which you have
you will get an extraordinary result and
you'd be very foolish to sell me 10 of
yourself for fifty thousand on the other
hand if you don't match it with that
your potential will in a significant
part go unused what other habits did you
cultivate in your 20s in your 30s that
you now see as being foundational to
your success as a business person well I
I knew a lot about what I do
uh when I was 20. I mean I I really read
a lot and and uh I aspired to learn
everything that I could about the
subject so intellectually I knew a lot
I did not know a lot about human
behavior I mean that that you can't
learn really out of reading books but
it's it's very important to understand
people and uh I say to the students
you know just imagine you could buy or
you or you could be given 10 of the
future earnings of one person that you
know among everybody you know now are
you going to pick the person that's the
smartest I got to pick the person that
can dance the best or that can run the
fastest or anything like that the right
height no anything no no there you're
gonna you're gonna pick the person that
has the right habits that that is
cheerful generous
gives other people credit for what they
do you know and when you look at all of
the qualities that you admire in other
people which would cause you to pick
that person say to yourself which of
those qualities can't I have myself
because they are
you know you determine whether you have
them so just write them down on the
piece of paper who is the person that
you admire the most or like the best why
do I like them and just write down and
then say which of these can I do myself
and the truth is you can do them and
then you also if you really want to
carry it to the next extreme you pick
the person you dislike the most and why
do you dislike that person you know and
you know they always they're never fair
about things basically they always claim
more credit than they're doing
everything and write down those
qualities and say if you dislike that in
some other person why in the world would
you want to have those yourself so you
just get rid of those and it's a pretty
simple thing to do but you want to be
the person that if you could pick your
best friend you know that you would have
the same qualities I'm 72 I'm getting
Social Security now so I'm you know I I
I should be in Florida you know pushing
shuffleboard around or something of the
sort but but I do what I can do anything
in the world I want to do but what I
want to do is run Berkshire Hathaway now
why do I want to run it that way
a I get to paint my own painting I go
down there every day and I feel like you
know I feel like Michelangelo they're
you know working on the Sistine Chapel
or something nobody else may think it's
a great painting but I get to paint my
own painting I do not have people second
guessing me
I do not have people saying why don't
you use a little more red paint than
blue paint why don't you paint a
Seascape instead of a landscape I get to
do my own thing I get the it's it's it's
a form of creativity it's it's exactly
like somebody feels it's a professional
golfer or somebody feels it's a painter
they're not doing it for the money
primarily we've got a company flight
safety where the trains more pilots than
anybody in the world flight safety is
run by an 85 year old man Al yulshi Al
started the company and with ten
thousand dollars in 1951 it now trains
four or five times as many Pilots as a
non-military Pilots as any as anybody in
the world
and he is there at 85 and then it's a
matter of public record he's got a
billion dollars worth of Berkshire
shares he works seven days a week he
loves it and he loves it for the same
reason then I love what I do he gets to
do it his way he buys these big
simulators that you train pilots in he
doesn't have to check with me as to
whether to spend 15 million dollars for
a simulator he doesn't ask me he knows
so much more about it than you know that
I do why in the world would he ask me
well I can't tell what kind of a plane
I'm in you know what I'm flying around
and and Al is spending a couple hundred
million dollars a year on simulators uh
suspending Berkshire Hathaway money and
he never checks with them all he's never
had to come to Omaha uh for any kind of
meetings he runs his own business and
that's what he loves in life and I let
him do it I mean that's my contribution
to it is is really turning loose his
energies and you know they were properly
directed before we bought the company
seven or eight years ago why do why
should I think that you know he couldn't
keep running it after that and like I
said 85 he's still running it and that
feeling of ownership is really
extraordinary and it's so much better I
mean it's the way I like to work uh and
it's the way you know it's the way uh
Susan jock likes to work it's the way Al
Yoshi likes to work somebody once said
that the chains of habit are too light
to be felt until they're too heavy to be
broken
[Music]
I have been terrified of public speaking
do it I'd throw up
and I know if I didn't cure it then I've
never cared
and so I saw an ad in the paper for the
Dale Carnegie course which worked on
developing your ability to speak in
public and I went down there
a good smile has the same effect as a
puppy's tail they made us do all these
crazy things to get out of ourselves and
so we stood on tables and did all kinds
of things
[Music]
[Applause]
if I hadn't have done that my whole life
would have been different
so in my office you will not see the
degree I got from the University of
Nebraska you'll not see the Master's
Degree I got from Columbia University
but you'll see the little award
certificate I got from the day on
Carnegie of course you have over a
hundred billion dollars of cash
Berkshire does it yeah
Berkshire has over 100 billion in cash
and you say that you always want this
company to be a fortress so how much
cash should an ordinary investor have on
a percentage basis do you think it
depends on their personal situation on
that it uh
it
if if you're working in something where
you're you're living off your your your
paycheck from week to week you want to
have a little cash around and you
certainly don't want to have a credit
card that's maxed out or anything like
that uh but if you know if if your house
is paid off if you don't have big living
expenses you got a portfolio of of
decent Diversified businesses
uh I don't really need any cash decent
genes for certain things and in my own
case I was sort of wired for Capital
allocation and being wired for Capital
allocation a couple hundred years ago in
Nebraska wouldn't have been a thing uh
and and even now being born in various
parts of the world it wouldn't have been
much but here I was in this
soon to be very rich capitalistic system
and and it just so happened that what I
did paid off enormously in a market
system like we have and I if I'd had a
talent in some other area that was way
less commercial I mean I would have I
would have had a good time doing it but
it wouldn't have paid off like this but
of course Jay said it perfectly when he
talked about you know he's in a
recording for himself and the money
comes afterwards I mean I I got to do
what I love I mean and it doesn't get
any luckier than that if if you can
spend your lifetime and I'm 80 now and
doing things you love every single day I
mean I would be doing what I did what I
do now and I would have done it in the
past if the payoff had been in seashells
or sharks teeth or anything else it
if you can go to work every morning I
tap dance to work you know and I come
down and I every day is exciting I I was
terrified for example both in high
school and college I don't know when it
started but I became terrified of public
speaking and uh I just couldn't do it I
mean I I and so I arranged all of my
classes so I never had to do any public
speaking and I got to Colombia and I saw
an ad in the paper uh for Dale Carnegie
course and I went down it was somewhere
in the mid 40s and I gave the guy a
check for a hundred dollars and I went
back and stopped payment I lost my nerve
and then I came out I got out of
Columbia actually when I was 20 and I
came out to start selling securities in
Omaha and I realized I had to get up and
be able to get up in front of people I
couldn't go through life this way so I
saw an ad again in the uh local paper
that there was a Dale Carnegie of course
being given I went down and I gave the
fellow a hundred dollars in cash and I
became associated with 30 other people
in the class we couldn't stand up in
front of a group and say our own name I
mean it was we were it was pathetic but
that class changed my life in a big way
as a matter of fact they used to give a
pencil every week for whoever did the
most with what they learned the previous
week and during that class I proposed to
my wife and she accepted and I won the
pencil that week
so it it's important I mean there's
certain you've got to be able to
communicate in life and it's enormously
important and probably the schools to
some extent under emphasize that I mean
you could start going for an MBA and
people think it's kind of beneath them
to teach you about communication but if
you if you can't communicate if you
can't talk to other people and get
across your ideas or write either you
know you're giving up your potential and
you know anybody that's got her career
potential of X I guarantee it'll be 150
percent of x if they uh if they really
learn how to communicate well so that
was that was a big a part of really
succeeding in my career if you want
another amazing Warren Buffett clip
check it out right there next to me at
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there